hey I'm John I'm Christina and this is
the gadget lab show we have a bunch of
cool stuff this week tablets augmented
reality two cans and a string but first
the news and WWDC what's up this time
around so WWDC tickets went on sale
earlier this week 530 a.m. pacific time
and they sold out in two hours that's
the fastest they've ever been sold out
and this year it went on super early and
if I had this right a lot of developers
on the west coast we're left completely
ticketless and it's causing sort of a
big controversy right right so there's a
lot of developers out here in Apple's
own backyard didn't get tickets to WWDC
people have gone for two years 12 years
they're diehard Apple developers and
they can't go this year is the tickets
went on sale so early in the morning
you've reported some are really pissed
off outraged what was the funniest
comment you've heard so far from a
developer who couldn't go um let's see
so I mean the reason developers want to
go is because you get this chance to
have one-on-one time with Apple
engineers and so it's a chance to solve
these bugs that may be plaguing your app
and so when developer he was like um if
you don't go to WWDC you're totally
boned the rest of you it was great it's
boned people so just is there any
recourse for these devs who can't go um
maybe if they know someone who knows
someone there might be a few reserve
tickets to get students have a chance to
grab at some scholarship tickets um
other than that just have better luck in
2013 other than that you're boned is
what it comes down to okay so Google
Drive what is this and how does it
compare to other cloud services yep so
Google Drive was finally announced this
week um you know it integrates your
google docs with cloud storage kind of
like dropbox but you know now it's on
google kind of a few years too late I
don't know are you excited about it I'm
not excited at all it's five gigabytes
of free storage after that it's
you paid stuff to expense cloud storage
how exciting can it be yeah okay so
that's the big news we're going to look
at some 22 tablets that run androids OS
what's up tablets how's it going how's
it going yeah there's a lot of action on
the 10 inch android tablet space right
now we had two new devices come our way
over the last week one is the asus
transformer pad right here and the other
is the acer iconia tab a510 and they
actually have a ton in common they both
have the same size screen at 10.1 inches
both have a 1280 x 800 solution you know
not not too bad they both have the same
quad-core processor but what does that
all mean wrightwood which one do
actually yeah you and how does compared
to the ipad that's the big question
everyone has about Android tablets yeah
yeah well no doubt um these are both
fast devices you know when you're using
apps when you're playing games when
you're surfing the web listen to music
because they both have quad-core
processors speed is everywhere and you
aren't going to feel as though this is
slower sluggish that being said I don't
feel as though it's makes the iPad feel
slow or anything like that where you're
really dealing with here is a different
ecosystem in Android so you are going to
have different apps and you know widgets
that you can move around on on the
device and maybe a little bit more
customization but it's just kind of a
different thing altogether really and if
you had to pick out the best features
are the worst features of these two what
are we really what's the big takeaway
from these two yes well it's funny
because with Android being an open
operating system that anyone can put on
their hardware everyone's looking for
some sort of differentiator because they
really do kind of act and feel exactly
the same so for acer they have a thing
called the ring and you just tap the
ring icon at the bottom and this deal
comes up here you can check out your
bookmark websites maybe some favorite
apps you can customize what shows up and
then you can even increase the volume
all right here
on the left or right as well which is
all kind of helpful i'm not a huge fan
of this i kind of feel like it's a super
superfluous touch on top of the
operating system yeah nothing too
special to me and you know asus actually
take some more hands-off approach it's
pretty much just straight-up Android Ice
Cream Sandwich as you know it and maybe
you like it or not I don't know it's on
both tablets but they don't really have
as much that they have some different
widgets that a little bit more unique
but it's just kind of their own version
of what everybody else has to now this
is actually a lower-cost version of the
transformer prime yes so what do I give
up if I buy this tablet instead of the
transformer prime yeah the transformer
prime basically it's exactly the same
this version has a plastic back instead
of an aluminum back so maybe a little
bit style maybe it's not as rugged but
it does look good and you know honestly
you save a little bit of money that's
the screen same screen the screen is
actually a little bit different it's not
covered in gorilla glass so it looks in
my opinion not as pretty as a
transformer prime it still looks good I
do like the screen on the transformer
pad that I'm better than I like the
iconia tab screen even though the iconia
tab goes for about four hundred fifty
bucks and this one goes for about 400
okay well we will have full reviews on
gadget lab and due time and next up
we're going to check out a really cool
augmented reality app okay Robbie mr.
augmented reality take it away with this
awesome new app so the lemons science
museum has a new exhibit and part of
that exhibit is an app now the app is
called James May science stories and
what it lets you do is take James May
one of the presenters from Top Gear one
of the best shows on BBC anything
actually one of the best shows on
television and James is a huge Science
Guy so he goes through and he tells you
about you know nine of the exhibits but
it doesn't a very unique way they're
using augmented reality so it's like you
have a tiny James May that goes around
with you teaching you about light bulbs
engines the Model T all these these
these items in this exhibition of modern
marvels
now we can't all go to London so you can
actually download a marker you can just
go to the site and download it and you
can have James May in your house telling
you about the Model T or rolls royce
engine right and so there's one
downloadable marker for each exhibit in
the museum actually you don't have to
download it once the app you can you can
scroll through the app to find whatever
exhibit you want James May to talk to
you about and just scroll through to you
find the one you want and just point it
here and then James May kind of talk all
in me and it's 360 degrees 360 degrees
if you if you if you turn it if you're
facing the camera this when you turn it
this way you can see the top of James
Mays head which I don't know if you want
to see but you can you can put the paper
down you can spin it around and James it
may well spin like he's on some sort of
carousel or lazy susan right it's
actually really so you really don't even
need to go to the music well they have a
lot more engine what I mean you can get
the 9 most important if they're
important enough for James May they're
good enough for me and they're good
enough for gadget lab too well thanks
Robbie for that illuminating look at
augmented reality science and speaking
of science we're going to look at the
most forward reaching technology and tin
can to lopunny so Alexander what are we
happier they look like tin cans with
cables coming out of them that is almost
exactly what they are this is a tin can
and inside is basically a microphone and
a speaker and this mini one can attach
to a cell phone like this here and
basically what you can do is talk to
people using it yes it's a Kickstarter
project right right it's a Kickstarter
project that launched a couple weeks ago
from the guys at monkey wrench design
and yeah they're just trying to raise
money to basically get this project
started and these are real tin cans I
think this one came from canned corn
right and have you tried it does it work
I haven't tried this one but I have
tried this one which is actually made
out of tomato paste can and it does work
you can just talk into it and the people
on the other side can hear you
when you just listen in and you can hear
it so for some reason you will not use
traditional technology that is sleek and
modern you could go back in time and use
your tin-can to talk to friends right
it's a throwback a strange one at that
so that was the gadget lab for this week
we will see you next week with more cool
stuff